ray is a tech savvy guy and loves to
spend most of his time exploring the web
on his laptop
one fine day he was going through an
article on futuristic gadgets and
suddenly he noticed an ad for the ps5
popping right beside the article
he found it a little strange as he
recalled searching for that just a few
hours ago
later that day he came across some
suggestive ads popping up related to
buying future leading gadgets
and that is when he freaked out thinking
how can it be possible that what he was
searching for just a few hours or days
ago on the internet is now suggesting
ads related similar to them
so he thought of going to his elder
brother aaron who is a software engineer
in an mnc
upon understanding the situation
he explained to ray that all of this is
happening because we are in an era of
web 2.0
it all started in 1994 when web 1.0 was
introduced to the internet
basically web 1.0 was all read only
content that was not interactable and
was similar to a huge wikipedia page
but after a few years in 2004 web 2.0
came into the picture
web 2.0 made the internet much more
interactive because of developments in
web technologies such as javascript
html5 css3 and others which allowed
companies to create interactive web
platforms like youtube facebook
wikipedia and many more
he further added that when we seek out
information or data of any kind from any
web platforms present on the internet
simultaneously unknowingly we also
provide them with information related to
our choices and interests which are
stored in cookies which later they sell
to various companies who make use of
this data to advertise exactly what you
were looking for
and this is how ray was able to see ads
of his concerned interests
ray was fascinated by how the internet
has evolved and how it works amazingly
but at the same time he was concerned
about the lack of privacy offered by it
ray out of his concern asked aaron is
there any way that one can get rid of
the loopholes of the current web 2.0
when aaron answered yes there are a lot
of ways to do that using tor browser
incognito mode etc
but these are not permanent solutions
and there can be fluctuations in their
reliability
but this scenario can be changed not
just for you but for everyone using the
internet with the help of web 3.0
ray was curious about it and asked what
is web 3.0
erin explained that web 3.0 is the next
step in the evolution of the internet
allowing it to process data with near
human intelligence through the use of
artificial intelligence and blockchain
technologies
that run innovative programs to help
users by providing them with their
relevant choices
it's a significant step toward open
trusting and permissionless networks
aaron further added to fully comprehend
this we must first explore the four key
features of web 3.0 first is
decentralization
blockchain will help to centralize data
storage while also establishing trust in
the virtual world
because web 3.0 allows information to be
retrieved based on its content
it can be kept in several locations
simultaneously
making it decentralized this would
dismantle the vast databases currently
maintained by internet giants like
facebook now meta and google giving more
power over people
second is trustful and permissionless
web 3.0 will also be trustful and
permissionless which means that
participants will be able to interact
directly without the need for a trusted
intermediary or permission from a
governing body due to this you can
access any data relevant to your choice
without any permission from any other
node or third party for example
if you are researching for some data you
don't need to accept its cookies or you
don't need to provide any sort of
details as there is a trustful bond
between you and the web
third is artificial intelligence and
machine learning
in web 3.0 through technology based on
semantic web ideas and natural language
processing
computers will be able to understand the
information in the same way that people
do
for example i love paris and i heart
paris may seem different in syntax
however their semantics are nearly
identical this will help the user to
achieve more relevant content to their
choices and will provide them ease with
internet browsing
fourth is connectivity and ubiquity
in web 3.0 the internet will be
accessible to everyone anywhere at any
time
because iot internet of things
technology will launch in several new
smart devices
these internet connected devices will no
longer be limited to pcs and smartphones
as they were in web 2.0 understanding
the shortcomings of web 2.0 corporates
like amazon apple and google are
transforming their existing services
into internet 3.0 apps that abide by
these four principles
siri and wolfram alpha are two
applications that use web 3.0 features
after learning about this ray was
relieved by the fact that web 3.0 is
going to bring so much of a difference
not just in his life but also to the
society as a whole
so here's a question for you
how is web 3.0 related to blockchain
a
it helps create smart contracts for web
pages on the internet
b
it helps web 3.0 storage data in the
blockchain
c
it offers a decentralized experience to
its users
d
all of the above
please take a minute to think about it
and leave your answers in the comments
section below three lucky winners will
receive amazon gift vouchers
web 3.0 will offer a more personalized
and customized surfing experience and a
smarter and more human-like search
assistant and other decentralized
benefits
all of which are believed to contribute
to a more fair web
this will be accomplished by giving each
user control over their data resulting
in a richer overall experience
in a nutshell the internet will become
considerably more intertwined in our
daily lives when web 3.0 arrives
we hope you enjoyed this video if you
did a thumbs up would be really
appreciated here's your reminder to
subscribe to our channel and click on
the bell icon for more on the latest
technologies and trends thank you for
watching and stay tuned for more from
simplylearn
[Music]
you